it has not been a good week at mgm and
this might be bad news for stargate
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
[Music]
so
[Music]
right so it was announced yesterday
that the two big bosses at mgm have both
resigned
this came a bit out of the blue for a
lot of the employees at mgm um as you
know if you're a regular site tracker i
speak to people that work in and around
mgm and they were shocked by this news
and
quite frustrated by it
now i have to go back a little bit and
explain this story i apologize by the
wind sorry i'm on my holidays
so at the start of april there was a big
summit between amazon and mgm executives
that summit talked a lot about businessy
stuff but it also talks a lot about
projects and upcoming things
previous to that mgm employees did
actually
feel quite confident about the amazon
merger they were basically told that
very little would change that they'd be
allowed to carry on as a single entity
that they'd be able to have a lot of
independence when it comes to new
projects etc and that you know there's
nothing really to worry about
these resignations have kind of put a
bit of a stinker on that plan
or that thinking
a higher executive of amazon in a
statement basically has thanked these
two hype executives for their work
but then add a little caveat onto that
place is saying that
they're leaving will now allow
the
easier
merger between
um mgm and amazon to continue
and for the integration of mgm into
amazon to happen
right that was basically something they
were told would not happen
over the
period of the last year mgm have been
lied to a great deal it sounds like and
my sources are telling me that during
these big summits in the early april
they were told
very clearly that mgm would actually
become part of amazon
and that they would not be getting the
independence
they were promised
what does this mean for projects like
stargate
well
my sources are telling me lots of things
in the last 12 the last week so has gone
very very quiet
stargate was basically put on the back
burner
during these summits because
there's been some voices worried about
brad wright's involvement and whether
he's the right person to lead it um
people like michael burnett have been
talking very much about how should there
be some fresh blood some new people
involved in the project
that sort of put things back to the
drawing board because a lot of work had
actually been done getting ready for
stargate to be green lit things like the
budget being planned and so on and so on
that kind of put it all back on the back
burner again
this now
though these two
resignations
that puts things back again
the problem is going to be now that the
two people at the top of the tree mgm
obviously aren't going to be there in a
few months
amazon are going to be putting in new
people
this doesn't i don't think
changes anything about whether um
stargate will happen i think it still
will but when is the problem
i don't think we're going to be hearing
anything by july 25th like we hoped for
the 25th anniversary of july 27th sorry
for the 25th anniversary it's far more
likely it's going to be pushed back down
to next year
so all of our hopes
that we might actually get stargate this
year seem to be going out the window now
i do actually think amazon hoped that
stargate would come back this year i
think they hoped that the
merger would go through nice and easily
that the people at mgm would basically
play ball
it looks like
they've declined to
and that these two
resignations
were more pushes out the door
they didn't like obviously what amazon
had to say
um during this summit
and have been quietly asked to leave
if that is the case and considering that
it's both of them not just one but two
then
that does make it look like that exactly
the summit didn't go as well as planned
and as i say they didn't like what they
were being told
so at the moment
big trouble ahead amgm
let's see what happens over the next
couple of weeks and as soon as i know
more i will do a proper video
and get it all to you if you're new to
the channel please like subscribe hit
the bell notification really helps us
out i need to get back quickly because
the wife doesn't know i'm doing this
video
and um as always guys please stay safe
[Music]
you